تصاعدت التوترات بين الولايات المتحدة والمملكة
العربية السعودية بشكل حاد هذا الأسبوع مع
اتهام المسؤولين الأمريكيين للسعوديين
بتسليح أوبك بقوة لخفض
إنتاج النفط ومساعدة روسيا في الحفاظ
على آلة الحرب في أوكرانيا
التي نقلها
لنا السعوديون سرا وعلانية عن
نيتهم ​​في ذلك.  خفض إنتاج النفط الذي
كانوا يعلمون
أنه سيزيد الإيرادات الروسية
ويحتمل أن يضعف من فعالية
العقوبات
التي أوضحناها أن هذا سيكون
الاتجاه الخاطئ حيث أن خصم أوبك بلس
بما يصل إلى مليوني
برميل يوميًا قد هز البيت الأبيض
الذي يقول الآن إنه  إعادة تقييم
علاقتها بالسعوديين ، أحد
أهم حلفاء الولايات المتحدة في الشرق الأوسط
بعد أشهر فقط من سفر الرئيس بايدن
إلى جدة في محاولة لإصلاح
علاقة متعثرة بالفعل ، فأنا
في هذه العملية عندما يكون أه هذا
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ قد عادوا.
سيضطرون إلى أه ستكون هناك بعض
العواقب لما فعلوه مع
روسيا المتعددة  كما أخبرت rces لشبكة CNN
أن أعضاء آخرين في أوبك بلس ، بما
في ذلك الإمارات العربية المتحدة والعراق ، يعارضون
القرار الذي تقوده السعودية ،
وقد أشارت تلك الدول الآن للولايات المتحدة إلى أنها
قد لا تمضي قدمًا في نوع
التخفيضات الضخمة التي تريدها المملكة العربية السعودية من
أحد المصادر.  قال السعوديون إنهم
رفضوا إصدار إدارة بايدن
بيانًا مكتوبًا نادرًا
يتهم الولايات المتحدة بمحاولة
تشويه الحقائق والإصرار على أن القرار
استند فقط إلى اعتبارات اقتصادية.
استقرار أسواق النفط
حيث تدرس إدارة بايدن
كيفية معاقبة المملكة العربية السعودية ، قال مسؤول كبير
لشبكة CNN إنهم كانوا
غامضين عن قصد لإبقاء السعوديين في حالة
تخمين ،
لكن أحد الخيارات التي يفكر فيها المشرعون
هو حظر مبيعات الأسلحة المستقبلية
للبلاد بمجرد أن يصبح الكونغرس  مرة أخرى في الجلسة
، أعتقد أنه من غير المحتمل أن
ندعم أي مبيعات أسلحة إضافية
للسعوديين  لكمة في القناة الهضمية لا
توجد حاليًا مبيعات أسلحة وشيكة
إلى المملكة العربية السعودية في خط الأنابيب على الرغم من أن
الخبراء يشككون في أن
العلاقة ستتغير بشكل أساسي
بسبب أنشطة المملكة العربية السعودية
في الحرب في اليمن والخسائر المدنية
التي تسببت فيها بعد
مقتل  أصبح الكونغرس جمال خاشقجي
أكثر فأكثر انتقادًا
وسيطرًا على المبيعات العسكرية الأمريكية الخارجية
إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ،
ولم يتبق سوى القليل جدًا من الإكراه الذي يمكن للولايات المتحدة القيام به
في محاولة السيطرة على المبيعات العسكرية إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية.
الكثير من المسرح ومن غير
المرجح في نهاية المطاف أن تأخذ مليوني
برميل من النفط يوميًا من السوق ،
لكن الولايات المتحدة تتطلع إلى اجتماع أوبك القادم
في نوفمبر لمعرفة ما إذا كانت
المنظمة ستبقى على المسار ناتاشا
برتراند. سي إن إن واشنطن